[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants bonsoir les offres
aux patrons je descends tout de suite
j'ai trop envie de retrouver mes deux
petits j'habite nicolas est peu probable
que tu es pressé monde on honore ce we
vas-y vite mon petit doigt me dit que tu
ne vas pas t'ennuyer en leur compagnie
cheuvreux j front tu faisais une ourse
dans les chalets en bois
alors on est pressé de voir son doudou
par le son du public au crime
saïdi me
un joli vous avez fait de très bons
descend ce monsieur qui se sait le
capitaine jonathan tu connais pas son
histoire
alors on va te la raconter oui je vous
coupe le capitaine jonathan est âgé de
18 ans à turin jour un pélican dans unis
le d'extrême orient
le pélican de jonathan au matin ou un
oeuf blanc et le show américain lui
ressemblant étonnamment est ce que 6e
d'hélico bon à son tour alors stop la
musique ablement anneaux qui ont fait
autant cela peut durer très hautain si
on ne fait pas de métaphores long feu
trop de bobos et était notre histoire
comme trop rond
on dit quand tu auras fini de rire tu
viendras nature bonne nuit
[Musique]
pauline et moss pour tous non non j'en
aurai mieux ne rien lui raconte du tout
pu mener d'un prenait avec lui nicolas
dodier bonne nuit les enfants
et voici notre nounours oh oh
alors tu étais bien amusé potes vous que
lui sur l'histoire du capitaine jonathan
que te seront hélico mines en hausse à
je vais vous raconter aux le public hors
europe qui pondent temna racontera tout
à leurs noces
mongi pas trop haut la nuit enfin fait
douloureux
à
[Musique]